I guess the question is if this I G
report comes out as we expect it now
right before that December 11th
testimony does it in in essence bolster
Republicans even further to stand with
the president if it's this painted
picture of the beginning of the Russia
investigation that that has a lot of
question marks well look this is what
the Republicans have been waiting for
and they're hanging a lot on this
there's a lot of expectations around
this it needs to deliver I suspect there
will be a lot of unhappy people and I
suspect that people like McCabe and
others Comey and others are going to be
very unhappy when all that second point
out there's the IG report that had two
deals with the FISA allegations and then
there's John Durham the US Attorney from
Connecticut who's also doing a broader
look at the beginning of the Trump right
as important as this Inspector General
report is it is pretty limited it's just
about whether there was abuse of the
FISA process this was the way that the
Justice Department was spying on members
of the Trump campaign and how they how
they convinced a court to allow them to
do that this has always been a question
of either you had the Trump campaign
colluding with Russia to steal the 2016
election or you had some indication that
there was some really bad behavior on
the part of the Justice Department and
we have some indication we're going to
get a little bit more about that bad
behavior as it relates to the FISA abuse
but Durham is looking into all sorts of
things in addition to that as well we
expect that to take a lot longer I want
to turn to 2020 very quickly a new Iowa
poll out has Pete Budaj edged up
significantly making a big jump and you
can see the up and down 16 points there
Michael what's interesting in the our
poll number two is the president's
approval among Iowa Republicans still
very strong at 85% 76 percent saying
they're definitely going to vote for the
president yeah I mean President Trump
despite everything and you see these
numbers nationally that there are some
surprisingly to some people high numbers
in favor of this impeachment process
relative to the baseline approval
numbers but having said that those
approval numbers for President Trump
have been very consistent remarkably
consistent in the Democratic field
you're seeing churn I think this lead is
going to change hands many times over
and I wouldn't get too excited about one
poll but it is very interesting
particular
see a somewhat more centrist candidate
moving ahead yeah and South Carolina is
a totally different picture for Pete
Buddha judge in part because the
african-american support if you look at
this poll among african-american voters
in South Carolina out today people to
judge is that zero so it's not good
you're saying that's not good not good
behind Marianne Williamson not singling
her out but among african-americans
voted not gonna win the South carriage
is not gonna win the South Carolina
primary but if I'm Elizabeth Warren who
just five or six weeks ago people were
talking about oh she can't be stopped
she's unbelievable Pete moody judge if
he beats her in Iowa if she loses New
Hampshire to either him or Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren's going nowhere
fast
Biden leads in Nevada in the most recent
polling in Nevada he leads in South
Carolina by a Doughty margin it's hard
right now for somebody to explain to me
a good path for Elizabeth Warren today
dowdy I love the word dowdy okay